President Trump is waking up in Trump
Tower for the first time as president
demonstrators rallied outside as he
returned to New York City they protested
his response to the white supremacist
rally in Charlottesville Virginia over
the weekend the controversy led the CEOs
of Intel and Under Armour to quit a
White House panel last night Merck's
CEO resigned earlier in the day the
president specifically condemned the Ku
Klux Klan neo-nazis and other white
supremacists yesterday his statement on
Saturday criticized violence on many
sides Margaret Brennan is outside Trump
Tower Margaret good morning
good morning while President Trump
followed the lead of daughter Ivanka in
disavowing these hate groups he
consulted with his chief of staff and
his homeland security team a White House
official said that counterterrorism
adviser Tom Foster weighed in on exactly
how the president should address this
act of domestic terrorism the
controversy followed President Trump
back to his Manhattan home where he was
met by protesters like Alissa Kraus
during a brief stop in Washington the
President issued his first direct
condemnation of the white supremacist
groups racism is evil and those who
cause violence in its name are criminals
and thugs including the KKK neo-nazis
white supremacist and other hate groups
that disavowal of supremacist groups
came two days too late for some CEOs
serving on the president's manufacturing
council Brian krzanich of Intel said he
was resigning to call attention to the
quote divided political climate adding
many in Washington seem more concerned
with attacking anyone who disagrees with
them Under Armor CEO Kevin Plank also
withdrew they followed the lead of
Kenneth Fraser CEO of pharmaceutical
giant Merck who wrote that as a matter
of personal conscience he felt quote a
responsibility to take a stand against
intolerance and extremism within an hour
of Frazier's announcement the president
sharply responded now that Ken Frazier
of Merck Pharma from president's
manufacturing Council he will have more
time to lower ripoff drug prices yet
president Trump declined to explain his
delay in denouncing the hate groups
they have been condemned
now Labour leader Richard Trump at the
aflci old toad CBS News he's also
assessing his role on the panel and said
baby yet to even hold a single real
meeting Charlie we expect to hear from
the president later today when he talks
about investing in infrastructure thanks
Margaret